I'm now going to do a
bunch more examples
using the chain rule.
So let's see.
Once again.
If I had f of x is equal to,
let's see, I don't like this
tool that I'm using now,
let's have one of these.
f of x is equal to, say, x to
the third plus 2x squared
minus, let's say, minus
x to the negative 2.
We haven't put any negative
exponents in yet, but I
think you'll see that
the same patterns apply.
And all of that to, let's
say, the minus seven.
We want to figure out what
f prime of x, what the
derivative of f of x is.
So this might seem very
complicated and daunting to
you, and obviously to take
this entire polynomial to
the negative seventh power
would take you forever.
But using the chain rule, we
can do it quite quickly.
So the first thing we want to
do, is we want to take the
derivative of the inner
function, I guess
you could call it.
We want to take the
derivative of this.
And what's the derivative of x
to the third plus 2x squared
minus x to the negative 2?
Well, we know how to do that.
That was the first type
of derivatives we
learned how to do.
It's 3x squared and 2 times 2,
plus 4x to the first, or just
4x, and then here, with a
negative exponent, we do
the exact same thing.
We say negative 2 times
negative 1, right, there's a 1
here, we don't write it down.
So negative 2 times negative 1
is plus 2 x to the, and then we
decrease the exponent by
1, so it's x to the
negative 3, right?
So we figured out what the
derivative of the inside is,
and then we just multiply
that, that whole thing, times
the derivative of kind of
the entire expression.
So then that'll be, we
take the minus 7, let me
do a different color.
So this is the entire thing.
So then we take minus 7, so
it's times minus 7, this
whole expression, I'm
going to run out of space.
x to the third plus 2x squared
minus x to the minus 2.
That's minus x to the minus 2.
And all of that, we just
decrease this exponent
by 1, to the minus 8.
So let me write it all down
a little bit neater now.
So we get f prime of x as the
derivative of f of x is equal
to 3x squared plus 4x plus 2x
to the minus third power, I
don't know why did that.
That's minus 3.
Times minus seven times x to
the third plus 2x squared minus
x to the minus two, all of that
to the negative eight power.
And we could simplify
it little bit.
Maybe we could just multiply
this minus 7, times, we could
distribute it across
this expression.
So we'd say, that equals minus
7, so this equals minus 21 x
squared, minus 28 x minus
14x to the negative 3.
All of that times x to the
third plus 2 x squared minus x
to the minus 2 to the minus 8.
So there we did it.
We took this, what I would say
is a very complicated function,
and using the chain rule and
just the basic rules we had
introduced a couple of
presentations ago, we were able
to find the derivative of it.
And now, if we wanted to, for
whatever application, we could
find the slope of this function
at any point x by just
substituting that point into
this equation, and we'll get
the slope at that point.
Let me do a slightly harder
one, to show you that the chain
rule, you can kind of go
arbitrarily deep in
the chain rule.
OK.
So let's say I had, let
me see if I can write it
a little bit thinner.
If I had f of x, I don't know
if you can see that, I'm going
to do it a little fatter.
f of x is equal to, I want to
make it a little bit more
complicated this time.
3x to the minus 2 plus 5 x to
the third minus 7x, all of that
to the fifth, and then this
whole expression to
the third power.
So I imagine you saying, Sal,
you're starting to go nuts,
this is going to
take us forever.
Well, I'll show you, using
the chain rule, it will
not take that long.
So the way I think about
it, so-- f prime of x,
f prime of x equals.
I start off kind with
the innermost function.
So let me see if I can
use colors to make it
a little bit simpler.
Let's take the derivative of
this innermost function first.
Actually, let me give
you the big picture.
We want to find the derivative
of the innermost function, and
then a little bit bigger,
and then a little bit
more big than that.
I know that's not precise
mathematical terms, but
you'll get the point when
I show you this example.
So first we'll do this
inner function, this
inner expression.
And the derivative of
that's pretty easy, right?
It's 15x squared
minus 7, right?
that was pretty
straightforward.
And now we're going to want
to multiply that times this
entire derivative here.
So let me circle that in
a different-- so then
we want to do this.
We're going to multiply that
times this entire derivative.
Well, that's just times 5.
And we just pretend like this
is just an x here, right?
Because the derivative
of x to the fifth is 5x
to the fourth, right?
But instead of an x, we have
this whole expression, 5x
to the third minus 7x.
So we'll write that.
5x to the third minus 7x.
Now the exponent here
goes down by one.
So it's 5 times 5x to the
third minus 7x, all that
to the fourth power.
So we figured out the
derivative of this so far, and
then we want to figure out the
derivative of this, so we'll
add it, right, because we're
trying to figure the derivative
of this entire expression.
So this is an easy one.
Let me draw that in
a different color.
So we want the
derivative of this.
So that's negative 2 times
3, so that's negative
6x to the minus three.
So what have we done so far?
We've so far figured out the
derivative of this entire
expression, right?
The derivative of that
entire expression using
the chain rule is this.
And now, we're almost done.
We just have to multiply that.
So I'm going to just, I've run
out of space on that line, but
let's just assume that
the line continues.
So that's times.
And now we just take the
derivative of kind of
this whole big thing.
And now it's going to be the
derivative of, I'm going
to use this brown color.
So it's a whole big expression
to the third power, right?
So that becomes times 3 times
the whole expression, right?
That's 3 times, now I'm going
to write the whole thing, 3x to
the minus 2 plus 5 x the third
minus 7x, that to fifth, and
then you decrement this by
1, to the second power.
That was an ultraconfusing
example, and this is probably
the hardest chain rule problem
you'll see in a lot of
the questions you'll
have on your test.
You see, it wasn't
that difficult.
We just kind of went to the
smallest possible function, and
actually the smallest possible
function would have been one of
these terms, but we just found
the derivative of this, which
was 15 x squared minus 7, and
then we just used the principle
that the derivative of kind of
a function is just the
derivative of each of its
parts-- well, actually, the
derivative of-- we figured out
the derivative of this inner
piece, which was 15x squared
minus 7, and then we multiplied
it times the derivative of this
slightly larger piece, which is
5 times this entire expression
to the fourth, then we added it
to the derivative of
3x to the minus 2.
And then that whole thing, and
actually I should put a big
parentheses around here, that
whole thing, we multiply it
times the derivative of
this larger expression.
I think I might have confused
you, so I apologize if I have,
and in the next presentation
I'm going to just do a bunch
more chain rule problems, and
at some point, it should
start to make sense to you.
I think it's just a matter
of seeing example, after
example, after example.
I'll see you into the next
presentation, and I apologize
if I have confused you.